nous reprenons notre conversation avec
dali michigan qui va à petites touches
changé nos vies qui a le pouvoir de
changer nos vies et une de vos grandes
techniques c'est l'auto hypnose donc de
questions en quoi ça consiste
et est ce que c'est à la portée de tout
le monde alors en fait l'auto hypnose
c'est quelque chose qui est naturel à la
base c'est juste un processus parce que
beaucoup de gens des fois on peur quand
on parle de mots hypnose autohypnose les
gens des fois on est on des inquiétudes
de l'auto une hausse aiguë un processus
naturel c'est de vraiment se connecter à
la partie on va dire à son son soi même
façon moi intérieur et une fois qu'on
est connectée c'est là qu'on peut
commencer à changer mais en fait
l'esprit
il ya des techniques qui sont on va dire
pareil que lorsque vous voulez
travailler votre corps il ya des
techniques qui sont pressés ce que vous
pouvez faire alors lesquels pour pour le
clip no comment fait on concrètement ce
que depuis tout à l'heure en fait je
vous écoute et vous j'ai rien contre
vous vous êtes un très joli poséidon
c'est super
c'est une bonne publicité pour les
moustiques on porte des meufs comme des
haltères dont ça ça me plaît moins mais
sinon en fait moi j'ai vu votre site
alors vous avez vous aussi beaucoup de
faux faux followers est riche mais je me
demande s'il ya pas une grosse
supercherie derrière vous c'est beaucoup
de neuf millions trois cent mille cent
vingt mille élèves la 80 pays non alors
génial et j'ai l'impression que ça
marche pour vous vous avez l'air très
sympathique mais je trouve que vous
enfoncez beaucoup de portes ouvertes moi
j'aimerais une solution maintenant je
m'auto hypnotise d'accord alors qu'elle
menait avec quelques vous désirez dans
votre vie en ce moment j'aimerais
m'apaiser être moins agressif d'accord
et comment comment vous savez quand vous
êtes à pv et moins agressive comment
vous le savez en fait je vais je sais
physique moi ça se passe au niveau de
mon estomac d'accord sûr que je vais
plus souvent à la selle par exemple je
suis
on sait tous on est en famille quand je
suis à pas et j'ai effectivement les les
toilettes apaisé je suis content qu'on
crève l'abcès
cette situation allons jusqu'au bout moi
c'est vrai que tout est un peu dans
l'estomac des ronds dit que c'est le
deuxième cerveau du coup là et en ce
moment chez un peu stressé effectivement
passé des salles fêtes de fin d'année
vraiment hengy même personnel donc
j'aimerais vous m'aidiez à moto
hypnotisé pour être un peu plus en
harmonie avec moi-même
d'accord et quand vous êtes vraiment
bien en harmonie avec vous-même vraiment
qu'on vous senti super bien parce que
vous avez des moments dans votre vie
vous sentez bien
oui c est là qu est ce que vous
ressentez en fait quand vous quand vous
sentez vraiment bien que toujours des
choses en vous je sens une chaleur à
l'intérieur
effectivement je ne me sens plus légère
je suis plus joyeuse tous accès aux
toilettes
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors moi je vous conseille de le faire
c'est de prendre une micro habitués
d'accord c'est le faire quelque chose
par exemple que on va dire 30 secondes
par jour mais vous vous dites c'est
trente secondes là je les fais quoi
qu'il arrive c'est rare que je peux
choix en vacances que choix par exemple
je sais pas genre j'ai une journée de
travail incroyable et bah vous dites
basse et 30 secondes là je les fais mais
coûte que coûte
je vous dis cavale de trente ans mais
vraiment de la merde pendant 30 secondes
tous les jours voilà qu'est ce que vous
allez faire c'est que avant de dormir
bon d'accord là vous allez faire votre
session d'automne hypnose d'accord donc
pour simplifier la chose on va faire
vous allez faire six étapes encore donc
c'est des trucs très simple déjà en fait
vous allez bien sûr commencer par par
fermer les yeux encore juste avant de
dormir
et là vous allez vous répéter dans la
tête
donc ça peut être une voie que vous
entendez ça peut être votre propre voix
la voix de quelqu'un d'autre peu importe
mais vous devez écouter dans votre tête
votre objectif d'accor donc là vous vous
dites que vous voulez pas on ne peut pas
ma paisible je le répète l'un deux fois
à pest waapp est et ce qui est bien
c'est que de ressentir directement ce
que ça vous fait par exemple au niveau
de l'apaisement d'accord parce que là
vous avez des centrales sont ceux qui
prennent des missions en cours de route
donc on est
on est au milieu d'une session d'auto
hypnose ça peut paraître bizarre je
conte fabuleux début donc on en est à la
troisième étape wpt et voilà et une fois
que vous avez je me répète ça voilà vous
répétera et là maintenant ça va être
vous allez faire ce qu'on appelle une
induction une induction
c'est vous avez vous fait un processus
en vous même qui vous prouve que vous
êtes vous un état différent alors
j'explique un truc très simple par
exemple ce couple est alors qu'un pétard
en tout cas je suis sûr que ça marche
sur les téléspectateurs oui c'est pour
ça on va faire piquer un somme soit là
on manque un peu de talent afin qu est
ce qu elle va obtenir comme comme état
et comme comme bénéfice de bénéfices et
que le fait de faire ça tous les jours
même 30 secondes au départ après vous
allez vous sentir bien puis vous avez
prolongé votre temps et au bout d'un
moment après une fois que vous avez
vraiment compris ce processus en vous
vous allez pouvoir en fait utilisé ce
que vous avez déjà ressenti directement